>> Tucker: OVER TIME,
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LEADING
INDICATOR OF WHAT THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY BECOMES.
LET'S HOPE THAT IS NO LONGER
TRUE.
CALIFORNIA HAS NOW RUN FOR
POVERTY, HUMAN WASTE PILING UP
ABUNDANT SIDEWALKS, BANKRUPT
GOVERNMENT, AND VANISHING
MIDDLE-CLASS.
AND AT THE STATE DOESN'T SPEAK
ENGLISH AT HOME.
IT CAN CALIFORNIA BE SAVED OR IS
IT TOO LATE?
JOHN COX DOESN'T THINK IT'S TOO
LATE, HE WILL BE FACING GAVIN
NEWSOM IN NOVEMBER AND HE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
YOU GREW UP IN CALIFORNIA, YOU
LIVE THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
NOW THE CALIFORNIA DREAM IS TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO GET TO TEXAS.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THAT.
GAVIN NEWSOM WOULD RUN THIS
STATE EVEN FURTHER INTO THE
GROUND.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT WOULD
YOU -- AND IT'S SAD TO EVEN
REPORT ON IT BUT IT IS THE
BIGGEST STATE.
THERE ARE SO MANY PROBLEMS IN
CALIFORNIA, WE COULD GO ON FOR
THE REST OF THE WEEK.
BUT IF YOU WERE TOO NARROW IT
DOWN TO ONE THING YOU CAN CHANGE
ABOUT THE STATE TO GIVE THE
MIDDLE CLASS FROM FLEEING, TO
KEEP THE STATE FROM GOING
BANKRUPT, WHAT WOULD IT BE?
>> I WOULD HAVE TO SAY IT'S THE
TAX BURDEN PRIMARILY.
THE GAS TAX WILL BE REALLY A
PROBLEM HERE.
A STATE SENATOR JOSH NEWMAN WAS
JUST RECALLED YESTERDAY BY 60%.
THEY SPENT $8 MILLION OF SPECIAL
INTEREST MONEY TO TRY TO KEEP
THIS GUY AND OFFICE AND THE
VOTERS TURNED IT OUT.
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN THAT THE
VOTERS HERE ARE GETTING IT.
THIS ELECTION WILL PROVIDE A
STARK CONTRAST.
GAVIN NEWSOM TALKED ABOUT IT,
AND HE WANTS TO HAVE A CRADLE TO
COLLEGE NANNY STATE GOVERNMENT,
AS IF THIS GOVERNMENT ISN'T BIG
ENOUGH.
OR TAXING US ENOUGH.
HE WANTS TO EXPAND THAT.
HE WANTS TO DOUBLE THE INCOME
TAX, HE WANTS TO INCREASE
PROPERTY TAXES AND HE WANTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO NOT REPEAL
THIS GAS TAX.
I SAY THE PEOPLE OF THIS STATE
HAVE BEEN TAXED ENOUGH.
THEY ARE GOING TO REBEL AND WE
WILL LEAVE THAT REVOLT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK THEY
COULD EVER REPAY THAT MONEY,
IT'S TOO MUCH.
AND NOW THEY ARE PROPOSING TO
GIVE FREE MEDICAID TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
SO HOW WILL THE STATE EVER
AFFORD THAT, OR ANY OF THIS?
WHAT IS THE PLAN GOING FORWARD?
>> I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT WE
COULD GROW OUR WAY OUT OF IT BUT
I DON'T EVEN THINK THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO US.
WE WILL HAVE TO HAVE SOME REALLY
STARK, CLEAR CONVERSATIONS WITH
A LOT OF THESE EMPLOYEE UNIONS.
AS USUAL, IT'S THE EMPLOYEES WHO
ARE GOOD, THEY TAKE THE PIPE ON
THIS.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, TUCKER, THEY
HAVEN'T EVEN BEGUN TO PUT ANY
MONEY AWAY FROM RETIREE
HEALTH CARE, AND THERE ARE ALL
KINDS OF STATE WORKERS THAT ARE
RETIRING AT 53 OR 54 YEARS OLD.
THEY'VE BEEN PROMISED
HEALTH CARE UNTIL THEY QUALIFY
FOR MEDICARE, AND AS THEY KNOW,
MEDICARE IS GOING BROKE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
THE BIG PROBLEM OBVIOUSLY IS
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN'T PRINT
MONEY, AND ITS CREDIT RATING IS
HANGING BY A THREAD.
I AM A CPA, THAT WAS MY FIRST
DEGREE.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I HAVE
TO LEVEL WITH THE PEOPLE OF THIS
STATE ABOUT THE PROBLEMS WITH
THE UNFUNDED DEBT.
>> Tucker: I CAN'T IMAGINE
WHAT IT WOULD BE LIKE TO BE A
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT IN
CALIFORNIA, TO BE A MATH GUY AND